bonjour alexis je ravi de vous retrouver
en musique ce matin dans la matinale de
france alors manuel valls a peu apprécié
on a vu cette vidéo parodique d'une
chaîne espagnole de son départ de
barcelone est-il fâché avec son pays
natal on peut se demander oui cette
chaîne tv3 qu'il a qualifié de chaîne de
propagande pour l'indépendantisme
catalan s'est moqué de manuel valls eux
la toupie la girouette sur l'air de moi
lolita du coup on a tous dans la tête
moi je m'appelle manuel valls et c'est
vrai que c'est ce qui est très drôle
dans le clip c'est que à chaque fois
qu'il dit aimer barcelone et qui se
retrouvent dans un lieu ce n'est pas le
bon lieu et donc il n'est jamais au bon
endroit donc vraiment la chaîne se moque
de ses attaches par rapport à son pays
d'origine et c'est vrai que quand il est
parti de france fâcher un puisqu'il
n'avait pas ce qu'il attendait sans
doute attendait-il à ministère ou
davantage des vannelles macron il a
décidé tel un conquistador d'aller
récupérer la mairie de barcelone s'il le
pouvait et puis ça a été un fiasco à la
fois sain campagne et son élection en
tant que conseiller municipal de
barcelone obligés de manifester avec
l'extrême droite là bas à faire toutes
sortes de contorsions pour avoir un
micro strapontin au conseil de la ville
donc de nouveau déçu manuel valls se dit
allez j'écris un livre pas une seule
goutte de sang français ne coule dans
mes veines mais je reviens quand même
et le voilà de retour évidemment sur la
scène nationale française les espagnols
s'en moque je trouve qu'en france on lui
fait un accueil plutôt de digne d'un
exploit ministre avec le tapis rouge
dans tout le picking tinal dans toutes
les télés les radios une couverture
média incroyable pour son livre qui ne
se vend pas quelques centaines
d'exemplaires voire moins chaque semaine
qui s'écoule
c'est un fiasco également de librairie
et le voilà quand même qui revient sans
amour propre puisque comment faire après
ses adieux émouvants à l'assemblée
nationale en disant que voilà il
n'oubliera jamais mais que son avenir
maintenant est en espagne que son pays à
l'espagne
le voilà revenir la queue basse en
france en disant que maintenant son pays
finalement c'est la france alors bravo
aux catalans pour s'être moquée de cette
manière là de manuel valls qui a peu
apprécié évidemment la caricature il a
dit qu'il ne commenterait pas mais il a
quand même commenté
en tout cas l'ancien premier ministre
est il de retour sur la scène politique
française
et oui c'est à craindre l'ancien premier
ministre du mois comme je le disais a eu
droit à un plan média rêvée pour la
promotion de son livre il a pu faire
toutes les matinales toutes les tranches
d'invités politiques de france et de
navarre de catalogne
non heureusement qu'on a fait beaucoup
d'autres ça suffisait et et on le voit
aussi s'activer sur la scène politique
il se met en scène d'un alors il a bien
montré qu'il avait rencontré de marlène
schiappa et gérald darmanin au ministère
de l'intérieur en tant qu'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur pour parler de
la laïcité les débats aussi lui sont
plutôt favorable puisqu'on parle à la
fois de radicalisation islamique de
laïcité la manuel valls euh c'est quoi
faire on parle aussi de langues
régionales et il a été un farouche
opposant bien sur l'indépendance de la
catalogne alors que sa bio twitter et
écrit en crêpe talent il disait que non
attention aux langues régionales le
français est la langue de la france il
n'a pas mis encore à jour sa bio twitter
peut-être l'at-il fait pendant le week
end mais on le voit voit la girouette
trop rapide ça tourne trop vite pour
manuel valls
aujourd'hui on le sent évidemment
essayer de créer un micro-parti ou de
prendre en main une branche de la
majorité présidentielle pour compter
sans doute dans l'élection 2022 et
espérait revenir sur le premier plan sur
la scène politique française la question
c'est est ce que les français souhaitent
revoir manuel valls et bien la réponse
est loin d'être évidente
est-ce que c'est ses rapports avec
emmanuel macron à quels sont-ils et quel
rôle peut-il jouer pour 2022 selon vous
alors ses rapports avec emmanuel macron
ils sont compliqués puisque en marche
avait choisi de ne pas mettre de
candidat face à lui lors des élections
législatives pour ne pas l'humilier
parce qu'il aurait sans doute perdu
largement face à un candidat de la
république en marche mais néanmoins il
n'a jamais rejoint le parti des
mélomanes seront jamais officiellement
les deux hommes ne s'aimait pas
lorsqu'il était au gouvernement lui
premier ministre les malades macron
ministre à bercy
il y avait une rivalité énorme puisque
en fait emmanuel macron a fait ce que
rêvait de faire manuel valls il a mis la
main sur le parti socialiste en le
faisant dériver vers la droite de plus
en plus et donc toute la stratégie
politique du manuel s'est trouvée regard
10 est explosée par ce jeune
mais le maquereau inconnu au bataillon
jusqu alors qu'il a totalement enlever
du chant c'était se dégage isma c'était
ce renouvellement de la scène politique
et le voilà qui revient on est loin
évidemment du nouveau monde c'est
vraiment ce qu'il se fait de pire dans
l'ancien monde
manuel valls est quelqu'un qui n'a fait
que de la politique toute sa vie qui ne
sait rien faire d'autre
et on le voit bien il revient et il
réfléchit en politique politicienne
c'est à dire qu'il ne compte pas du tout
par rapport à l'opinion publique par
rapport aussi aux attentes des français
lui ce qu'il veut c'est de trouver un
poste un siège parce qu'il a le pin's
d'aix premier ministre parce qu'il sait
qu'il peut encore faire des choses vues
comme on l'invite vu comme il a encore
un certain crédit médiatique mais
politiquement je crois que manuel valls
est mort et que pour 2022 même s'il
voulait aider et mener le maquereau il
pourrait tout à fait le faire perdre
tant finalement il est entouré du norad
de perdants dorénavant et surtout d'une
aura de traître à la fois sur la primeur
la primaire pardon de la gauche mais
ensuite sur la façon dont il a lâchement
quitter la france et puis lâchement
quitter l'espagne parce qu'il n'avait
pas ce qu'ils souhaitaient de ces jeux
politiques auxquels ils adorent jouer
il nous reste quelques secondes alexis
est ce que son futur pourrait s'inscrire
à à gauche qui ont cessé de de ceux de
se ressouder
pour les élections alors peut-être au
sein du printemps républicains s'ils
tentaient que ce mouvement peut encore
être qualifiée de gauche sur le créneau
de la laïcité de la lutte contre le
radicalisme
il y avait peut-être une place pour
manuel valls sur cette fausse gauche de
l aile droite du maquereau disent qu'on
ne sait plus le en même temps c'est à
dire qu'il ne pourra pas retourner au
parti socialiste
la chose est claire mais qu'il peut
fonder effectivement une sorte de
mouvement ou s'insérer dans un mouvement
existants pour peser évidemment sur les
sujets de la campagne présidentielle de
2022 mais aussi pour être une
personnalité qui va revenir mais comme
je disais je crois qu'il ya une fatigue
énorme de la part des français de ce
personnage de manuel valls ce traître
est inutile finalement après les fiascos
nombreux que ce soit à la primaire de la
gauche puis d'une pause élections
successives et son bilan bien maigre en
tant que premier ministre donc ce type
de profil de politiciens historique et
dont le seul métier est de faire de la
politique politicienne
je ne pense pas qu'il plaise
aujourd'hui et même il détonne dans le
nouveau monde souhaitée par emmanuel
macron ça pourrait être un boulet pour
le président sortant qui souhaite se
faire réélire plutôt qu'un atout
merci beaucoup alexis pour toutes ces
précisions c'est l édito d'alexis
poulain comme tous les lundis
[Musique]